- La décision d'auraire de ce
que doit faire le gouvernement
Trudeau.
- La décision d'aujourd'hu vérie
triomphe des politiques qui sont
- Steven Guilbeault, ministre
fédéral de l'Environnement est
avec nous en direct. Monsieur
- Bonsoir, Patrice.
- Le... C'est la v
la politique de la terre brûlée,
a dit un de vos anciens
collègucologique. L'opposition
dit : "Est-ce qu'on avait
vraiment besoin d'un milliard de
nouveaux barils de pétrole d'ici
30 ans au Canada?" Monsieur
vraiment avec cette décision-là?
STEVEN GUILBEAULT,ral
Environn. et Chang. climatique
- Patrice, c'est une décision
qui était évidemmen a à enn a àn
prendre hélas souvent lorsqu'on
gouverne pays de 37 millions de
personnes. Cela étant, nous nous
sommes engagés, lorsque nous
d'évaluation environnementale,
de le dépolitiser. J'écoutais
les membres de votre panel dire
qu'il fallait dépolitiser un
ces choses-là, bien, c'est
exactement ce que nous avons
fait avec évaluation
environnementale.
Et là, j'ai un groupe d'experts
udié ce projet pendant
quatre ans et qui me fait une
recommandation en disant :"Biene
projet n'a pas d'impact
significatif." Cela étant, le
promoteur a 137 conditions qu'il
condition qui n'a jamais été
imposée au Canada dans aucun
projet, c'est-à-dire que le
projet soit net zéro,
- Ça me fait penser, vous allez
sursauter, mais à Donald Trump
qui disait : On peut faire du
propre." Ça me fait penser à ça,
que vous êtes en train de dire
qu'un milliard de barils de
pétrole de plus, de plus, que ce
qu'on fait, bien, finalement,
c'est un projet vert. C'est  dee
plus, Monsieur Guilbeault.
- Ce n'est pas du tout ce quas n
projet vert. Ce que même le GIE,
dans son rapport, nous dit qu'ou
près 35-36 millions de bari
monde carboneutre. Donc, ça va
diminuer énormément, on va
passer de 100 millions à 35.
L'agence de l'énergie dit même
ons de barons de barons de baro.
Moi, voiture. Je n'en aurai
probablement jamais. Et quand je
prends le train pour venir à
Ottawa, ce train-là fonctionne
au pétrole. Et j'aimerais vous
débarrasser de notre dépendance
au pétrole au cours des
prochaines années, même au
Québec.
Vous dites un milliard de
Savez-vou8,$<Orespond à
combien de consomm
pétrole juste pour le Québec?
Avez-vous une idée? C'est sept
ans.e l'ai dite l'ai dite l'ai t
d'entrée de jeu.
- Alors,r que ça paraît
beaucoup, c'est un très grand
chiffre, mais nous consommons
t réduire t réduire t réduire t.
Et le plan que nous avons déposé
la semaire, qui a été
encensé par la plupart des
experts, même les écologistes
ont dit très
solide, ce plan-là repose sur
des données de régulateur
gie du Cangie du Cangie du Cangt
une augmentation de pétrole d'à
ès un million de  barils
d'ici 2030.
Alors, nous, on avait déjà
déposé la semaine prochaine. Et
ce que nous nous sommes enga
à faire, c'est d'éliminer
progressivement les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de tou
- Mais, Monsieur Guilbeault, je
vous auriez
pu, politiquement, comme
gouvernement, dire non. Vous
- Bien, c'est certain qu'on
aurait pu dire non
effectivement.
ne veut pas accroître la
capacité pétrolière du Ca
encore plus.
- Bien, si on avait fait ça, on
un processus
qu'on a cherché à dépolitiser au
cours des dernières années. et s
experts le soin de fairel'évalue
ça, il faut prendre le risque...
il faut vivre avec les
Si on fait comme les
conservateurs à l'époque et que
tout est politique, bien, là, on
Et je vous soulignerai quand
même que ce même groupeenvironns
projets, nous a dit : "Non, il y
a trop d'impacts." Le projet
Laurentia, dans le port de
Québec, l'agence ece projet-là
aurait trop d'impacts.
- Mais là, vous me parlez...vout
environnemental du projet, de la
plate-forme, des 30 puits, etc.
Ça, que ce soit mieux fait par
une compagnie du Danemark qu
ce n'est pas ça. La question qui
est posée, et qui
cabinet fédéral, je présume,
c'est : est-ce que, compte tenu
de ce qui arrive, 'on
sait depuis des années, est-ce
qu'on en
message à la planète que nous,
on va accroître notre production
Je ne vous dis pas de couperner
que non, et que le pétrole va
années. Mais d'accroître encore,
comme symbole poli
Guilbeault pour vous, j'imagine,
ça doit être dur à avaler,
vraiment.
- C'est certainement trèsconscis
allons continuer à consommer du
pétrole pendant de nombreuses
2050.
- Oui, mais pas besoin de
l'accroître, Monsieur
Guilbeau
ce qu'on veut consommer du
pétrole qui émet 10 fois plus de
gaz à effet de serre par Barrie
que celui de Bay du Nord? Et
ux. Et vous avez peut-
être vu aujourd'h
l'Environnement du Canada, qu'il
y a un projet de sables
l'avant. Trois millions de
tonnes de CO2 par année versus
250 000 tonnes pour le projet de
Bay du Nord, alors
vraiment 10 fois p Dans un monùa
continueilililililililililililil
faut aller vers le pétrole qui a
le moinsaz à
effet de serre. Et le projet de
Bay du Nord est l'un de ces
projets-là.
- Oui, mais vous, c'est que vous
partez d
collectivement d'accroître notre
point-là. Or, on peut refuser un
projet très polluant en Alberta
et refuseuveeuveeuveeuveeuveeuve
aussi. On peut faire les deux
choses.u principe
qu'il fan àn àn àn àn àn àn àn à
l'un ou l'autre. Je pars du
principe que, dans la mesure où
r
pendant un bout de temps, aussi
bien consommer le pétrole qui a
le moins d'impacts sur
l'environnement et qui, en p
- Steven Guilbeault, est-ce que
c'est la
la solidarité ministérielle. Et
vous dites : "Je vais peut-être
à
démissionner?
. Écout. Écout. Écout. Écout. Ée
veux dire, c'est un projet
symbolique, je peux comprendrenu
pays, nous avons un plan dex chs
climatiques qui montre comment
nous allons atteindre nos
un pays dans le monde,producteu,
qui dit : on va mettre un
plafond sur les émissions du
nous sommes en train de faire.
Trouvez-moi un pa
objectif de réduction de la
pollution de méthane, qui est un
gaz à effet de se
est en voie d'atteindre 45 %,tie
méthane dans le secteur du
pétrole et du gaz. Méthane qui
e
réchauffement. 75 % d'ici 2030,
il n'y a aucun autre pays au
mis
en place des mesures comme
celles-là. Nous somme très
ambitieux, mais nous allonsntinu
pétrole.
- Très bien. Mais reconnaissezut
je vais vous laisser là-dessus,
que le symbole que ça aurait
envoyé,
un nouveau projet de cette
ampleur, encore une fois, on
certains, c'est un
gouverner pour l'ensemble de la
population, pour l'ensemble des
intérêts de landu la
questione c'est ce que nous
cherchons à faire.
- Très bien. En t
vous avez à choisir votre ce nea
pas aujourd'hui, on s'entend.
- Je vous remercie, Patrice.t, e
fédéral de l'Environnement et du
Changement climatique, nous a
parlé en
- Merci. Au revoir